okay hello everybody this is probably
going to be the last main lecture on
numerical methods and ordinary
differential equations there's always a
chance that there will be kind of
fifteen minutes here or there later in
the class but what I really want to do
is finish off talking about numerical
integration of OTS and systems that
exhibit chaos okay so what we're gonna
do is we're going to go back through the
lorentz system that we looked at before
and we're going to kind of take that
initial cubic volume of particles and
we're gonna make it tighter and tighter
around an initial condition to see how
even a very small change in initial
conditions can lead to very very
different behavior in this system then
we're going to look at the double
pendulum physical example as an example
of a system that exhibits chaos it's one
of the simplest physical systems and
then if I have time I'll show you some
other cool examples and then Wednesday
and Friday and probably a little bit
next week we're gonna be talking about
linear algebra and then leading on to
vector calculus okay so kind of we're
gonna close off the class with linear
algebra and vector calculus and yeah
okay any questions so far
don't okay so let's look at this example
just one more time
so since the last time we talked I tried
to make this a little bit nicer example
so before we had this cubic volume of
initial conditions for minus twenty to
twenty in the x y&z directions and we
use the mesh grid command down here mesh
grid to create these three dimensional
arrays of x coordinates Y coordinates
and Z coordinates and then we could step
through these with a for loop you know
for I equals 1 to whatever for J equals
4 k equals but
was super slow so we wrote a vectorized
version of this code that simultaneously
integrates every point in that volume
one DT forward in time okay and I'm
adding this little line here instead of
keeping the view constant at an angle of
20 degrees and 40 degrees
I'm having my view change for every time
step so this is going to rotate the
volume as at the time steps go super
simple one line but it looks way cooler
okay so I'm gonna start with this really
big large cube of initial data we're
gonna run it and this is what we saw
last time except it looks way more
awesome because the view is rotating
okay just one more time okay so what do
you notice right off the bat when you
run this code okay there's a couple
points to don't move I think there is a
fixed point in this system what else do
you notice
Fagen okay there are two kind of
swirling entities so the thing that I
notice pretty quickly is that within one
or two time steps we had a
three-dimensional cube of data and very
very rapidly it gets sucked on to these
two-dimensional looking wings okay
so that's kind of an odd property of
this system that eventually everything
gets attracted on to these very very
thin almost two-dimensional looking
structures okay but it's a lot denser
with particles in some places than
others some places it has kind of very
few particles and so this is actually an
example of what is known as a fractional
dimensional attractor okay so the actual
butterfly wings that are attracting all
of these particles are not exactly
two-dimensional they have a fractional
dimensional kind of like like the coast
like the pacific coast if you zoom in
farther and farther and farther you see
more and more detail that's similar to
this fractal structure and we call this
system dissipative if you know your if
your volume is contracting okay so this
is contracting volumes onto a lower
dimensional surface or it's compressing
trajectories okay so that was one
example now what I want to do is I want
to start with a much smaller cube of
data so instead of minus 20 to 20 in
every direction I'm gonna do minus 1 to
1 in every direction and I'm gonna start
around that initial condition that we
used earlier - 8 8 27 this is kind of
the initial condition that we were
looking at a couple lectures ago ok so
if I just run this part we see this is
my initial cube of data just this little
box now so it's much much smaller and
when I run this code you see that this
little box very rapidly gets stretched
and folded and stretched and folded and
it gets pulled like taffy until
eventually it would cover the entire
two-dimensional butterfly attractor ok
so whenever you see trajectories that
are getting pulled and folded like taffy
that's another kind of hallmark
signature of chaos how many of you have
actually seen taffy pulling machines
like at the carnival or the fair you
should Google or YouTube like taffy
pulling because this is exactly what
taffy pulling is like in fact there are
two pegs usually that are moving around
folding the taffy and there's actually a
really great mathematician at the
University of Wisconsin who studies
chaos and like bread making machines and
taffy pulling machines and he's found
the optimal way of pulling taffy or
folding bread based on on chaos mixing
okay so that was the second example with
a smaller cube of data so finally we're
gonna take an even tinier cube of data
so instead of -1 to 1 we're gonna do
minus 0.1 to 0.1
so this is a really miniscule little
point red point of data you can barely
see it it's right here okay and we're
gonna do the same thing we're going to
run this through our integrator for
about five time units and finally at the
very end it gets stretched and folded
okay
so there's a few things to note here
first of all is trajectories get folded
in stretching stretched by this chaotic
system so if you wrote down the
equations of this and you looked at the
origin you'd find that that origin was a
saddle point okay so the saddle point
has an unstable direction where
trajectories are getting stretched in
that unstable direction but then they're
getting attracted in other directions
and stretched again and attracted and
stretched again and the tighter I start
my initial conditions the longer my
trajectory stay together right the
smaller I made this cube the longer my
initial conditions stayed together but
eventually they always stretched and
fold and they'll always eventually
exponentially separate from any initial
condition okay are there any questions
about this example
okay so I told you that in so I told you
that in chaotic systems there's this
fundamental property that trajectories
that start epsilon close to each other
will exponentially separate in time and
I also told you that we could write down
local and global error approximations
for our integrators remember we had four
runge-kutta four for the RK four
algorithm which is ode45 we have
something like a local error which is
order delta t to the fifth and we have a
global error which is order delta T to
the fourth okay so what assumption did I
make that allowed me to say that every
time step every time I step my
trajectory forward I pick up this kind
of delta T to the fifth error what were
my basic arguments for saying that this
was order delta T to the fifth the
number of terms in your Taylor series
expansion yeah if you actually wrote out
your approximation and then you Taylor
expanded the true solution they would
agree for the first four powers of delta
T and then they would start to disagree
okay so this error is really because our
approximation is only capturing so many
terms of the Taylor series of the true
solution that doesn't care at all about
whether or not your system is chaotic or
not the local error is always order
delta T to the fifth and it doesn't care
if you're dealing with a simple very
very simple system like a linear
pendulum or a very very complicated
system like a nonlinear double pendulum
or the Lorenz equation okay what
assumption do we make to get this order
delta T to the fourth global error term
so the global error was always one power
of delta T smaller than the local error
why was that
you can find errors in your speed okay
so so the idea of global error is to
actually integrate a trajectory I'm
gonna have a whole bunch of Delta T's
right I'm gonna take a little delta T
step here then here then here then here
and so on and so forth I'm taking a ton
of these little Delta T steps and if I
make delta T smaller I have to take more
steps right so the number of steps of my
integration that I have to take to make
this trajectory are proportional to one
over a delta T okay so I'm assuming that
I have 1 over delta T of these local
steps and that they add up to give me
this global error but what that assumes
is that every time I have an error it
just stays exactly that kind of error
forever and I can add up all of the
error for all of these little local
steps in my trajectory and they add up
to this global error okay but this is
not true for chaotic systems any idea is
why this global error notion doesn't
work for chaotic systems
okay let's let's say that I have one
tiny little local delta T to the fifth
error at my first time step so after my
first time step I end up here at this
blue point instead of this black point
where I want to end up and now from now
on let's assume that I never have any
error introduced ever again so I
introduce one tiny little Delta T to the
fifth error but I never from now on my
integration is perfect what happens in a
chaotic system right this little epsilon
error grows exponentially in forward
time right this is like a different
initial condition and these trajectories
are going to grow farther and farther
apart exponentially at least for a short
time forward in time so the problem with
integrating chaotic systems is that
every single one of these little tiny
tiny epsilon errors gets magnified
exponentially in forward time because of
this the chaos of the system any change
in initial conditions even from
numerical error is gonna cause those
trajectories to go to totally different
places so this little epsilon error gets
multiplied by e to some lambda T where
lambda is a positive number and this
lambda is called the Lyapunov exponent
the a panov is one of the most
controversial e spelled names in all of
physics okay
so this little epsilon error in fact
every single little error local error
gets magnified exponentially in forward
time and then eventually this can't grow
to infinity because you're kind of bound
to some physical attractors so this
error will saturate at some point but
eventually the error will become as
large as the physical domain on which
you're simulating so in the case of the
Lorenz attractor
if I start with two trajectories that
are epsilon apart for a short time they
will split apart exponentially quickly
and then eventually they can they have
to both stay on this attractor so they
can only be so far apart you know after
a really really long time so the error
will saturate it'll look exponential at
first and then eventually it'll saturate
to the size of the domain okay so this
is a long way of telling you that it's
very very difficult and dangerous to
integrate numerically chaotic solutions
so if you have a chaotic system and you
want to simulate it numerically it's a
really dangerous thing to do even a
great integrator like OD 45 is going to
have problems because no matter how
small this error is if you multiply it
by e to some lambda T it's going to get
huge really really quickly right so this
epsilon could be ten to the minus
sixteen machine precision and if I had
eetu the you know let's say my lambda
was plus one if I had times e to the T
this is going to become order one kind
of a huge error pretty quickly and about
time equals 30 or 40 in about 30 or 40
time units this machine precision error
will become order one and you can
actually estimate how long it'll take
your error to grow to some threshold
tolerance where you can't tolerate it
with a very simple formula like this
okay if you know the Lyapunov exponent
of your system which people have
calculated for the Lorenz attractor and
you can calculate you can tell when this
error is going to get larger than some
threshold value that you your tolerance
okay
okay before I keep talking are there
questions about this notion of your
little errors getting bigger and having
difficulty with integration
well so there's a natural question which
would be what should I do when I have a
chaotic system right how do I actually
control my error and make sure that I'm
not doing something stupid because like
very very often people simulate chaotic
systems one time and they plot the
trajectory like I mean I just did this I
plotted the Lorenz trajectory and I told
you this is the solution but I didn't
check the error and I didn't take my dt
and cut it in half and I didn't do any
smart things to try to check that this
was actually where the solution goes so
the first thing you would do if you have
a system and you think it might be
chaotic is you can take your trajectory
and you can cut your delta-t in half and
see take twice as many time steps and
see if you basically get the same answer
okay that's one way to see if your
trajectory is correct or not and what
you'll usually find if you do this is
let's say I have some some solution I'm
just gonna draw this cartoon okay let's
say I have some solution that I've
simulated in time and if I cut my delta
T in half or maybe I cut it by a factor
of ten what I'll probably find is that
it agrees really well for a long time or
for some time but then no matter how
well I cut my DT in half it might start
to do something different okay and you
could try to then cut that DT in half
and it might agree for a little bit
longer but then it's gonna do something
different and you could cut that DT and
a half and so on and so forth and
eventually you can't cut your time step
any smaller okay so there is a
fundamental time where if you integrate
your chaotic solution for long enough in
time you don't actually like it's the
wrong solution your numerical integrator
is not actually capturing that
trajectory okay so you would cut your DT
in half and you would find that it
agrees for some time maybe to here and
you'd say okay this part of the
trajectory is good and the rest of the
trajectory is probably bad so what can I
do in this case
you could start it over
okay so there's there's a fundamental
problem here any integration scheme like
RK for all the integration schemes I've
told you about have fundamentally been
designed to truncate a solution at some
order of a Taylor series or said another
way all of our integrators are designed
to agree with the Taylor series up to
some order that was like how we cooked
up some of these integrators like
forward Euler backward Euler runge-kutta
they're designed to have a specific
error in a specific way but it means
that you always have those little order
delta T errors that are magnifying
exponentially so there's no way you can
possibly make one of these integrators
so that it will simulate a chaotic
system well because any tiny tiny
epsilon error is gonna get exponentially
multiply okay so it turns out that there
is an entirely different class of
integrators and I'm gonna tell you a
little bit about them and then if you
want to know more you're gonna have to
kind of look them up on your own these
are research level integrators one of
them is called symplectic and the other
one is called variational okay how many
of you have heard of symplectic or
variational integrators before okay so I
know most of you have heard of the
Hamiltonian and the Lagrangian okay so
Hamiltonian and Lagrangian so the idea
here is so Hamilton's equations and
Lagrange's equations are nice
generalizations of F equals MA
if your system is constrained in some
weird way like this double pendulum is a
great example of a system it's really
hard to write down Newton's laws for
this double pendulum but it's very easy
to write down the Lagrangian or the
Hamiltonian
Sounion because we can write down the
total potential energy and the total
kinetic energy and there's rules for how
these systems evolve if you know the
potential and kinetic energy in terms of
the variables okay so when I let the
system go there are some equations given
by Hamilton's equations or lagrangian's
Euler Lagrangian that determine how the
system moves and so instead of trying to
write an integrator that satisfies any x
dot equals f of X I can write down very
very special symplectic or variational
integrators that are especially designed
to simulate Hamiltonian or Lagrangian
vector fields because Hamiltonian and
Lagrangian vector fields are very
special and have special structure so
what are the hamilton equations so if I
have some Hamiltonian which is
oftentimes kinetic plus a potential
energy what would the Hamiltonian
equations be the hamilton equations
somebody has to know right ok let's say
that my Hamiltonian is a function of
positions Q and Momentum's P ok this is
like in quantum mechanics or classical
mechanics you have Q dot equals partial
H partial p and p dot equals partial h
partial Q and one of these has a
negative sign and I never remember which
ones which does anyone know which one
this one all right so you had these very
very special equations they're kind of
you can derive these from the Euler
Lagrange equations that we used earlier
and so instead of writing an integrator
that very carefully agrees with some
Taylor series expansion up to fifth
order what we can do is we can make an
integrator so that every time I advance
Q and P there's a constraint that Q and
P have to stay on the same Hamiltonian
energy surface they have to preserve
conserved energy okay so instead of
taking a step forward and saying oh is
my error you know like 10 to the minus
16 which isn't going to do us any good
for a chaotic system I take a step
forward and I say how far it has my
energy moved
did I just gain a little bit of energy
and if so I better modify my solution so
I keep exactly the same conserved energy
variational integrators are a little
more general they can serve other
quantities like total angular momentum
or weird quantities but both of these
integrators are built on the fundamental
principle that instead of trying to
minimize local delta T errors you should
be trying to maintain some conserved
quantities of your system that you know
are conserved total energy angular
momentum things like that so oftentimes
in classical mechanics you learn about
no--there's theorem which tells you
something about the conserved quantities
of your physical system and for every
conserved quantity you can cook up a
special integrator that will conserve
those quantities and it happens to be
much much better at simulating chaotic
systems okay so I'm going to do this
example of the double pendulum this is
my favorite system that has chaos or one
of my favorite systems because it's so
simple and you can build it and bring it
to class and this is the closest class
I've ever had to my office so I only had
to lug this through one building which
was nice so the idea here is if I start
this system as close as I can to the
same initial conditions and let go the
two pendulums agree for a little while
they're actually doing really well but
then after a short amount of time they
go to fundamentally different solutions
they just do different things forever
after so it's a lot like this blue and
black curve on the board okay I'm gonna
start it again so I can start these this
is kind of the the best initial
condition because it's just low enough
energy that they actually do agree but
it has enough energy that the chaos
that's in pretty quickly
and so this is a real mechanical system
I want to get the point across that
chaos is not just an artifact of
numerics it's not something that you
have to worry about in numerix real
physical systems I mean these are very
tightly controlled precisely machined
double pendulum with the same bearings
basically the same age they've been
sitting in the same room for a long time
and it's impossible to machine them and
get the initial condition so close to
perfect that they agree forever okay
because any error in how they're made in
that fundamental equations or in the
initial conditions are going to grow
exponentially in time now if I wrote a
numerical integrator and I did this
about 10 years ago for a project if I
wrote a numerical integrator to simulate
these double pendulum if I used a 4th
order Runge Kutta scheme like OD 45 what
you would find so if I had the total
energy in time what should happen is
that my energy should stay constant in
time forever if I don't have any
dissipation right in a numerical
simulation this is a conservative system
my energy should stay constant in time
what really happens with OD 45 is that I
run this thing forward and very quickly
the energy starts to blow up to infinity
because all of those little order delta
T 2 v local errors were not chosen
cleverly and they add a city bias that
keeps increasing and increasing and
increasing the energy until very very
quickly there's no physical meaning to
my system my numerical solution just
doesn't mean anything because the energy
is so high I can't compare it to my
original system but a variational or a
symplectic integrator so if I wrote down
my equations in Hamiltonian form or an
Euler Lagrangian I wrote a discrete
integrator that preserved either the
Lagrangian or the Hamiltonian I would
get a solution that basically
kind of hovers around this the same
amount of energy forever just tiny tiny
tiny little machine perturbations about
that energy and that solution is much
better and it's much easier to get
converged trajectories that actually
agree with your real chaotic system so
that's what we use for planetary
simulations now and fluid simulations if
you can afford it are these fancy
variational or symplectic integrators
there's lots of types they're called
leap frog or ver lei or just symplectic
I'm not going to derive them it's way
too complicated and it would be a whole
class and kind of Lagrangian and
Hamiltonian mechanics to get to some of
these integrators but you should be
aware if you're ever simulating a system
and you really need to know very
precisely what the system is doing like
in a planetary motion scenario first of
all OD 45 is not going to work well and
second of all there are alternatives
that are based on actually maintaining
conserved quantities of your system okay
yeah
if you simulate okay and then take
measurements so if you're trying to
simulate okay so that's a good question
the question is if I was simulating a
planetary motion system why couldn't I
just simulate them for a day then take
new measurements and kind of repin my
simulations to those measurements and
then run them out again that is exactly
what we do in chaotic systems like
weather and finance so if you want to
simulate the stock market that's a crazy
chaotic dynamical system way more
chaotic than the double pendulum or
planetary motion it's like super chaotic
and so the only thing you can really do
is you start with some initial condition
you integrate the best model you have
and it starts to really deviate from the
data very quickly and then you reap in
your model to the measurements and you
start again and you reap in your model
to the measurements and you start again
so you could do this using something
like a common filter from control theory
that's a really nice way of
simultaneously assimilating some model
prediction that's wrong we know it's
wrong and some measurements that also
probably have error for a planetary
motion system we want to know what's
going to happen hundreds of years from
now because we want to know if there's
going to be a big asteroid that's gonna
wipe out earth
a hundred years from now because maybe
we could try to do something about it if
we knew it far enough in advance so it
doesn't really help us to pin the
measurements fifty years from now or 90
years from now or a hundred years from
now so we really need an accurate
simulation that will go as far out in
time as possible that's also what we're
looking for with climate models I mean
right now you can't wait ten years to
pin your climate model and see was a
good or did my data deviate and our best
climate models right now are really not
very good and they have huge deviation
in just about 40 or 50 years
so getting better - ility simulations
the problem with weather and climate
models is we don't actually have the
right equations it's not an initial
condition problem we don't have the
right fundamental physics built into the
model we don't know what the effect of
clouds
are you know we don't know if they're
positive or negative feedback in some
cases okay so I just spent 30 minutes
really ragging on OD 45 so at the end of
this you probably think OD 45 sucks and
we should never use it that's not true
OD 45 is a great all-purpose integrator
lots of systems you simulate are not
going to have a ton of chaos you know if
you want to simulate the trajectory of a
baseball not a super chaotic system so
lots and lots of systems you would try
OD 45 but you should always make sure
that if you cut your DT in half you get
the same trajectory that's just a
common-sense thing to do is that's
called convergence checking and if it
doesn't converge you should start to
explore why it doesn't converge and look
at you know nearby trajectories and see
if if the system really is chaotic okay
so I had this double pendulum in my
office all the time if anyone wants to
come play with it or build one or
anything you certainly can I have an
undergrad build me a cart to move this
thing around last summer and he's just
putting the finishing touches on it so
soon we'll be able to do feedback
control experiments on this which is
nice because it's a simple simple
example of chaos okay so I want to show
you some YouTube videos but I also want
to go back to what we talked about
before with ordinary differential
equations okay so I don't remember what
the equations for this double pendulum
are but they're relatively simple to
derive with euler lagrange with a
lagrangian and then the Euler Lagrange
equations and I think we maybe did it
but the bottom line is that I have some
equation in terms of theta 1 theta 2
Omega 1 and Omega 2 dot d DT equals some
big function of theta 1 theta 2 Omega 1
and Omega 2 okay I have four variables
that define the system
I have the angle of the bottom pendulum
at Stata one and it's velocity Omega dot
and I have theta2 the velocity of the
second pendulum sorry the position of
the second pendulum and omega 2 which is
its velocity and then there's some you
know big nasty nonlinear oh de in terms
of those four variables that tell me
what the system is going to do so how
many fixed points do you think the
system has physical fixed points i love
the system because you don't have to
write down any equations you know
everything that's gonna happen just
based on your own intuition what initial
conditions can I start this pendulum at
where it will not do anything sorry okay
zero zero this down position where all
of my variables are zero clearly a fixed
point so I'm not doing anything and it's
staying there right
are there other fixed points okay
straight up pi pi if I could perfectly
balance this in a vacuum this would
probably stay perfectly vertical at
least for for a little while right
nominally this is a fixed point but it's
an unstable fixed point because if I
perturb it even a tiny epsilon and I let
it go then it goes completely away from
that fixed point and with friction it'll
eventually go to the pendulum down
solution so that's the only stable fixed
point okay but there are two other fixed
points what are they it turns out
there's none that that have that
actually there are things called
periodic orbits where that will happen
but there are no fixed points yeah
yeah okay so the down-up like this
so can everyone see this on the TV
screens yeah okay so for the down up the
black pendulum the kind of big pendulum
is stable right this is kind of like a
normal stable pendulum motion but the
blue pendulum is unstable okay so this
is a classic example of before we talked
about saddles and centers well this
system has a center direction the black
direction is a center direction and the
blue direction is a saddle direction so
even having one saddle direction makes
the system unstable so that when you let
it go it you know does something else
and that eventually goes to the pendulum
down solution and the other unstable
solution is the up-down configuration
now the blue pendulum is the center
direction and the black pendulum is the
saddle direction okay so there's this
fundamental geometric interpretation of
what's happening to this system where
the motion of this pendulum is is
mediated by these saddle points and
center points and fixed points I told
you the system is chaotic but if I start
it with low enough energy near the
stable fixed point so if I start both of
them like this there's no chaos at all
they just do the same thing forever
until they die off okay so you need to
have energy large enough that you're
kind of above the energy of one of those
saddle points those like you need energy
above this saddle point to really have
bad chaos okay and the other great thing
about this pendulum system is that the
equations for this pendulum are almost
identical to the pent of the equations
of a three-body problem seems completely
bizarre and weird but I told you before
that if you had the Sun and Jupiter then
you have these fixed points here
and you have these energetically
forbidden regions where your asteroid
can't be and it turns out that these
fixed points are mathematically exactly
like the down-up pendulum configurations
two of the directions of this system are
centered directions if you linearize the
equations you would get two conjugate
pairs of I imagine Arriaga values that
are centers and you would get one
direction that's a saddle just like in
this pendulum system and so the reason
that I want to study control of the
double pendulum the reason we're putting
this thing on a cart is so that we can
essentially give it very very energy
efficient control to swing it up to the
pendulum up solution or to the down up
solution because if we learn how to
control this complex chaotic system in a
low-energy way then we learn how to
develop space mission designs to control
this system in a energy efficient way
and people are already doing this so
there are a series of missions to
explore Jupiter's icy moons called the
Jupiter icy moon orbiter Jimo mission
the u.s. cancelled this program and the
Europeans picked it up and now it's
called juicy so juicy will orbit the
Jupiter icy moons soon and it's
essentially based on control of a system
that has nearly identical equations to
this double pendulum very hard to
simulate because it's chaotic and so
they use things like symplectic and
variational integrators have to simulate
these trajectories because they want to
know what's gonna happen months and even
years from now okay any questions about
the pendulum or the planets before we go
to youtube yeah
soon fixed properties right so small
yeah so that that's a really good point
these these symplectic and variational
integrators are assuming that you
actually know the equations really well
the Hamiltonian or the Lagrangian are
kind of perfect and if you could just
simulate those perfectly you get the
solution that's not going to be true for
this pendulum I won't be able to get a
physical solution because the air
resistance and vibrations of friction
and the bearings or things that I can't
model and modeling those equations
better is not going to help me the
planetary motion is a great example
where like really these are huge
planetary bodies we know their masses
and moments extremely well and they're
so large that perturbations are small
anything we don't know is kind of
infinitesimal compared to how big
Jupiter is so if we know Jupiter and the
Sun and Saturn and we know all the
primary bodies and we know the equations
of motion then we can theoretically
predict this for thousands of years
accurately because the perturbations are
small enough yeah but that's a really
good point okay so just a couple of
YouTube videos that I love to show with
double pendulum cuz they're pretty cool
so the first one is a group in tu vien
that has actually built a controller to
stabilize the double pendulum so it's
pretty awesome
this is a very very hard problem so from
down bringing the pendulum up it's a
very hard nonlinear control problem it
has been solved for about a decade and
then you can bring it back up to that
one and up to the top so this might look
really esoteric but it actually has a
very huge range of applied uses for this
kind of control so for example the down
position is a lot like a gantry crane
and gantry crane swings is something
that's really important to minimize in
industrial settings the space X or the
Blue Origin Rockets are great examples
of inverted pendulum that you would want
to stabilize so I called the company
that made this swing up pendulum setup
and they charge some ridiculous amount
of money like thirty thousand dollars so
I have an undergrad build one for two
grand so there's a great question here
for those of you who are interested in
controls of what you have to measure in
a system to actually control it so if
you notice there are these black knobs
on the top and the bottom
those are position encoders so they can
encode very very accurately what angle
this pendulum is at so you can
approximate derivatives and positions
from those two encoders which are
necessary for the closed-loop feedback
to swing the system up so you need to
actually know what its state is you need
to know the state vector to be able to
do control on it
okay it just keeps going on okay
so here's an example I told you about
this planetary motion of the three-body
problem so here's kind of an example of
the Sun and Jupiter and this is starting
from an asteroid or a spacecraft that
has very very low energy so that it has
a lot of forbidden region everything in
gray is a place where it can't live and
this green saddle point is that Rank 1
saddle that kind of saddled cross Center
across Center that we were talking about
and I think there's one where they had
this thing in the rotating frame
somewhere
this is what it looks like in the
rotating frame right because the Sun and
Jupiter both rotate okay
the last example I want to show you I've
told you a lot about systems that are
chaotic but lots of systems are not
chaotic and so one of the characteristic
hallmarks of chaos is that if you start
with a relatively close initial
condition or a relatively ordered
initial state it will become disordered
so there's a notion of entropy
production and chaotic systems most of
you have heard of the great Russian
scientist Coleman Gaurav right from
turbulence and fluid mechanics
well Calma Calma Gaurav famously noted
that chaotic dynamical systems produce
entropy information entropy because if
you start with the same initial
condition plus some little bit of
information error that error will grow
and that's a lot like entropy but for
information and dynamical systems and he
really did this to turbulence and
turbulence control and these are still
ideas we use now to shape turbulent
attractors based on this idea of chaos
that Kolmogorov taught us but there are
also lots of systems where the system
actually becomes more ordered with time
so not all systems are chaotic lots of
systems are actually become more regular
let me crank up the volume
okay so these are a bunch of metronomes
and notice that they're on a table
that's swaying a little so it's a really
flexible table
how many of you seen something like this
before yeah
so we're just gonna watch for a couple
of minutes because this gets really
really interesting
pretty amazing it's already starting to
synchronize
it's just getting better and better and
eventually they are completely
synchronized so any idea why this
happens so you can actually reproduce
this at home really easily you can take
two cans of coke and a plank of wood and
if you put two or three metronomes on
that they will synchronize so all you
need is for your platform to be like
have a degree of freedom so that when
the pendulums move they like force this
thing and it brings so there's a weak
coupling these are just simple spring
pendulum but they each have a weak
nonlinear coupling to each other via
this table that can move and so you
actually get this great synchronization
event another example of synchronization
and complex systems are fire fly firing
so there are large groups of fireflies
that will actually synchronize and start
to strobe together which is kind of
amazing all of the behaviors here they
predict either regular motion or chaotic
motion live inside of the ordinary
differential equation for the system so
you really could tell what's happening
here based on this non-linear OD e what
the coupling looks like there's a lot
more here there's essentially a whole
field called dynamical systems and
there's a really good class on dynamical
systems in the applied math department
where you can learn a lot more about
kind of the geometry of these
differential equations yeah
these all start with very close
frequencies but of course there are
manufacturing errors and so even the
frequencies lock you no nearby
frequencies will face a rule lock the
London Millennium Bridge a bunch of
people walking across calls that to
resonate and synchronize and it almost
took the whole bridge down ok that's it
for today next time we'll talk about
linear equations